epa staffers were shocked to receive
this email obtained exclusively by CNN
which says we have been directed by the
administrator to withdraw the
restrictions the proposed protection of
that pristine area was being removed
oh no that pristine area filled with
these gorgeous salmon will be
obliterated by a mine at least that's
the impression you'd get watching CNN's
two-part exclusive I would have believed
that except I happen to have reported on
that mine is part of a special for Fox
on the green tyranny pursued by today's
rich environmentalists the proposed
Pebble Mine is a disaster waiting to
happen bad ad comes from one of
America's richest environmental groups
the NRDC the National Resources Defense
Council imagine this natural paradise
destroyed environmental groups ran these
ads they made people believe on TV that
everything was going to die the truth it
turns out is that the mine wouldn't even
be on Alaska's Bristol Bay the proposed
mine wouldn't even be ten miles away or
20 miles or even 50 miles it would be a
hundred miles away did CNN mention that
no never
instead CNN made EPA director Scott
Pruitt look evil by suggesting right
after a meeting with the minds boss he
gave the mine a go-ahead he made that
decision without a briefing from any of
AP A's scientists or experts what
shocking without consulting scientists
Pruitt's gonna let a company Massacre
these fish but in fact he hadn't given
the mine a green light he's simply
allowing them to submit an official
proposal Obama's EPA had rejected the
mine before it even looked at an
environmental impact statement that's
unheard of the EPA normally asks for
that environmental research examines it
and then accepts or rejects it doesn't
reject things without looking at them
Pruitt's allowing the review process to
go
it was proper CNN's reporter did Italy
speak with the mind CEO although he
sneered at the boss's reaction to the
decision it comes with no apologies and
do you think it was not wrong that mr.
Pruitt did not even look at what the
work had been done not a science
decision it's a process decision this
looks like a head of a gold mine went
into the new administrator and got him
to reverse what an entire department had
worked on for years the reporter was
accurate there the entire department had
worked on killing the mine for years
they were colluding with zealots and
environmental groups lots of those
people want no mines built anywhere
don't believe me listen to my interview
with their spokesman there are some
mines where an RDC says great this go
ahead well where it's not funny yeah
it's not up to us to greenlight mines
but what you don't complain about oh
yeah sure
we asked him for some names we're still
waiting CNN also made claims like this
the mind could potentially create a
footprint bigger than the island of
Manhattan and nearly as deep as the
Grand Canyon according to the EPA it
could but it won't the actual pebble
proposal is much smaller pebble CEO
isn't some monster destroyer of the
earth he's a Democrat who ran
environmental policy for Bill Clinton
and Al Gore CNN never mentioned that
either
instead the reporter called him a guy
who wants to mine gold in an area that
many scientists believe will destroy one
of the most pristine sockeye salmon
spawning grounds in the whole world what
am I missing what you're missing is if
they're right then we won't get a permit
right but explaining that now the mind
must begin the EPA's long and detailed
environmental review wouldn't fit CNN's
theme evil Trump appointee ravages
environment we asked CNN why didn't you
mention that and that the mine would be
a hundred miles away they didn't get
back to us
if environmental zealots and their
sycophants of the media get
away America will be a place where there
is no mining no new pipelines no oil
drilling no new anything people used to
say NIMBY you can build just not in my
backyard
now it's banana build absolutely nothing
anywhere near anybody
you